in the last video we introduced the idea
of parallel resistors these two
resistors are in parallel with each
other because they share nodes and they
have the same voltage across them so
that configuration is called the
parallel resistor and we also showed
that these two resistors could be
replaced by a single resistor we label
this one r1 this is r2 we show that we
can replace r1 and r2 by an equivalent
parallel resistor with this expression
here for two resistors R P 1 over R P
equals 1 over r1 plus 1 over r2 so
that's how you calculate the equivalent
resistance for two parallel resistors
now you can ask and it's a good thing to
ask what if there's more resistors what
if there's more resistors in parallel
here what if I have r3 and r4 and RN
all connected up here what happens to
this expression
so like we did before we had a current
here and we know that current comes back
here ah
the first current split some current
goes down through r1 some goes through
r2 and if we had more resistors some
goes down through our three as some goes
down through RN so the current basically
is coming down here and splitting
amongst all the resistors now all the
resistors share the same all the
resistors share the same voltage so
that's just V let's label V that's just
V they all shares the same V and they
all have a different current assuming
they all have a different resistance
value so we do exactly the same analysis
that we did before which was we we know
that I here has to be the sum there's
the summation symbol of all the I's I 1
plus I 2 plus I 3 plus I and that's as
many as we have so we know that's true
and we also know that the current we
also know that the current in each
individual resistor I n is equal to 1
over that resistor times V and V is the
same for every one of them so now we
substitute this equation into here for I
I for I we get the bigeye the overall I
is equal to voltage times it's going to
be a big expression 1 over r1 plus one
over r2 plus one over r3 plus as many
resistors as we have
one over r-n
like that and we do the same thing it
was we did before which was we say this
expression here is equivalent to one
parallel resistor we're going to make
that equal to one parallel resistors so
this whole guy here is going to become
one over RP that gives us a way to
simplify any number of resistors down to
a single parallel resistor and I'll
write that over here
so for an resistors multiple resistors
one over RP the equivalent parallel
resistor is equal to the same thing 1
over r1 plus 1 over r2 plus dot dot dot
one over R n so this tells you how to
simplify any number of parallel
resistors down to one equivalent
parallel resistor